>> CALLING ALL GLUTTONS FOR PUNISHMENT, ELON MUSK TWEETING
THAT HE'S ACTIVELY SEARCHING
FOR A NEW TWITTER CEO, A
POSITION HE IS REPEATEDLY SAID
WAS VIRTUALLY UNTIL-ABLE.
THE STAR SEARCHES OF GREAT
CONCERN TO TESLA SHAREHOLDERS,
ALARMED BY THE STOP SOMETHING
FALL FROM GRACE, DOWN 8%
TUESDAY, AND 60% YEAR TO DATE.
THANKS IN PART TO TWITTER
RELATED RISK.
CAN MASK TRULY FIND A
REPLACEMENT WITH APOLOGIES TO
NEW KIDS ON THE BLOCK HERE, THE
RIGHT STUFF?
PAUL LA MONICA JOINS US NOW, WHO
ALWAYS HAS THE RIGHT STUFF, THE
DANGER IS THE NEXT CEO GETS THE
STUFFING KNOCKED OUT OF THEM.
WHO MIGHT HAVE A?
>> I CANNOT BELIEVE YOU JUST
WENT NEW KIDS ON THE BLOCK, MY
TEENAGE SELF FROM THE LATE 80S
IS CRINGING RIGHT NOW, AS WELL
AS MY NEARLY 50 YEAR OLD SELF.
BUT ANYWAYS, ELON MUSK, HE
WANTS TO STOP RUNNING TWITTER,
BUT HE SEEMS TO NOT BE, YOU
KNOW, NOT BE CERTAIN THAT HE
CAN FIND SOMEBODY THAT CAN DO
THE JOB, AS HE TWEETED
YESTERDAY, I WILL RESIGN AS CEO
AS SOON AS I FIND SOMEONE
FOOLISH ENOUGH TO TAKE THE JOB.
AFTER THAT, I WILL JUST RUN THE
SOFTWARE AND SERVICE TEAMS.
ONE, NOT REALLY A GREAT JOB
POSTING.
HEY, COME TAKE THIS THANKLESS
STUPID JOB WHERE YOU WILL HAVE
TO REPORT TO ME, THE MOST
PREEMPTIVE MICROMANAGER ON THE
PLANET, AND IF HE'S RUNNING THE
SOVEREIGN SERVERS JAMES, WHAT
IS LEFT FOR THE CEO TO DO?
THE ADVERTISING BUSINESS THAT
MUSK IS TRYING TO DE-EMPHASIZE
AS THEY GO MORE WITH
SUBSCRIPTIONS AND TWITTER BLUE?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT MUSK IS
TRYING TO DO IT TWITTER.
TESLA AND VESTIGES STILL SEEMED
CONCERNED, THE STOCK IS UP A
LITTLE BIT IN PRE MARKET
TRADING, JULIA.
NOT THAT MUCH CONSIDERING THE
8% DECLINE IN MENTIONED
YESTERDAY AND THE GIGANTIC 60%
DROP THIS YEAR.
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
LOVE TO SEE MORE CONFIDENCE
FROM MUSK THAT HE IS GOING TO
JUST RESUME RUNNING TESLA AND
SPACE X, AND EVERYTHING ELSE
HE'S DOING, MAYBE JUST STOP
WITH THIS TWITTER.
>> YEAH, HE CONFIDED IN
SOMEONE'S COMPETENT --
IT'S A POINT HE'S EMPHASIZED ON
A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS, IT IS
GONNA TAKE SOME OF THIS GREAT
CONFIDENCE TO STEP FORWARD,
SNOOP DOGG, BECAUSE HE DID PUT
A TWITTER POLL OUT HIMSELF
SUGGESTING THAT HE WAS READY TO
TAKE THAT HOME.
AND UNLIKE ELON MUSK, IT WAS A
BIG FAT YES AND RESPONSE.
IT WASN'T AN INSIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
>> YES, OVER 3 MILLION I
BELIEVE VOTED IN THIS NEW POLL.
AND AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY,
81%, YOU KNOW, I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE THE NAME CALVIN JUNIOR ON A
SWEET OFFICE AND WHAT SNOOP
WOULD DO IT TWITTER.
HEY, IT CANNOT BE ANY STRANGER
THAN WHAT MUSK IS DOING.
OBVIOUSLY, SNOOP DOGG IS JOKING,
HE HAS A THRIVING MUSIC CAREER
THAT I THINK HE WANTS TO FOCUS
ON.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WALL STREET HAS BEEN
SPECULATING ABOUT, COULD CHERYL
SANDBERG, NO LONGER A META BE
SOMEONE WHO COULD INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE?
YOU HAVE DAVID SACHS, A MEMBER
OF THE SO-CALLED PAYPAL MAFIA
WITH ELON MUSK, HE MIGHT BE
SOMEBODY THAT, YOU KNOW, COULD
STEP IN AS WELL.
I THINK THEY'RE DEFINITELY
INTRIGUING CANDIDATES, AGAIN,
WHO WOULD WANT THE JOB THAT
ELON MUSK SEEMS TO BE
DENIGRATING AT EVERY POSSIBLE
TURN AND AGAIN, YOU HAVE TO
REPORT TO MUSK, WHICH LOOK AT
TESTA AND THE REVOLVING DOOR OF
EXECUTIVES THAT HAVE LESS
THERE.
IT'S JUST THAT HE MAY NOT BE
THE EASIEST BOSS TO WORK FOR.
ESPECIALLY WHEN SHE SLEEPING AT
THE OFFICE AND PUTTING IN 20 58
DAYS, WHICH, OBVIOUSLY DON'T
EXIST.
>> YES, PERHAPS BOTH REWARDING
AT TIMES AND ALSO EXHAUSTING.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, WE DO HAVE
SOME FUN WITH THIS STORY, I
KNOW IT'S NOT FUN FOR SOME OF
THE SHAREHOLDERS INVOLVED.
I WILL MAKE THAT CLEAR.
BUT A FRIEND OF THE CHAIR, AND
OF COURSE FACEBOOK, AS A MENTOR
TO MARKS A COBURG, WROTE AN
OP-ED, AN OPINION PIECE IN TIME
MAGAZINE, AND IT RESONATED WITH
ME, HE WROTE THAT AS MEDIA,
MAKING EXACTLY THE SAME
MISTAKES THAT WE MADE WITH
DONALD TRUMP, AS WITH ELON MUSK
NOW AND THAT WE'RE PROVIDING A
PLATFORM, WE'RE RAISING
ATTENTION, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IT CONSTANTLY.
WE'RE SORT OF PLAYING THE GAME.
HERE'S THE POINT ACTUALLY THAT
ELON MUSK HIMSELF IS MAKING,
ENGAGING NOW, ENGAGEMENT ON
TWITTER IS THAT RECORDS, THE
LEVEL OF VOLUME OF TWEETS BACK
AND FORTH AND FLYING AROUND OR
RECORD HIGHS.
PAULA, DO YOU THINK ROGER HAS A
POINT?
>> I THINK ROGER DOES HAVE A
POINT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING THOUGH IS
YOU DO HAVE TO WONDER HOW MUCH
THIS DOES REALLY BENEFIT MUSK
AND TWITTER OTHER THAN MAYBE
ELON'S INFLATED EGO, BECAUSE
LET'S BE HONEST, HE KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT TWITTER BEING A
TERRIBLE COMPANY AND, YOU KNOW,
FINANCIALLY, THAT THERE IS
BANKRUPTCY RISK, NOBODY WOULD
WANT THE CEO JOB, SO, I'M NOT
SO SURE THAT ALL OF OUR FOCUS
IN THE MEDIA ON TWITTER IS
HELPING TWITTER FINANCIALLY.
I THINK ROGER MAKES A GREAT
POINT THAT, YES, IN THE SAME
MANNER THAT MAYBE THE MEDIA
MADE MISTAKES BY GOING ALL IN
ON THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S SOON
AS HE DESCENDED ON THAT
ESCALATOR TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
AND THEN ACTUALLY WHEN THE
ELECTION IN 2016, IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT WE'RE PAYING TOO MUCH
ATTENTION THAT ELON MUSK, THAT
BEING SAID, AND OUR DEFENSE,
ELON MUSK RUNS SEVERAL
WELL-KNOWN COMPANIES AND HE IS
THE SECOND RICHEST PERSON ON
THE PLANET.
YOU CAN'T EXACTLY IGNORE HIM,
ESPECIALLY FOR FINANCIAL MEDIA.
>> YEAH, HE HAS PROOF HE HAS
GREAT BRILLIANCE AND CERTAIN
SPHERES.
THERE IS AN INNOVATOR AND A
VISIONARY.
SO, FINGERS CROSSED TO TURN
THIS AROUND FOR ALL THOSE USERS
THAT USE THIS PLATFORM.
PAUL, GREAT TO TALK TO YOU.
SO HERE TO DISCUSS IS CHIEF
BUSINESS CORRESPONDENT AND
"EARLY START" ANCHOR, CHRISTINE
ROMANS.
EVERY DAY --
>> YOU COULDN'T PAY ME ENOUGH.
THAT MAY BE THE TRUEST THING,
YOU COULD NOT PAY ME ENOUGH.
>> IT'S HIS PERSONAL COMPANY,
TWITTER IS, AND HE HAS TO FIND
SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING TO RUN IT
AND ESSENTIALLY WORK FOR HIM.
AND YOU'VE SEEN HIS ERRATIC
BEHAVIOR, DECISIONS AND RE
REVERSALS OF DECISIONS AND JUST
RIFFING ABOUT WHAT THE COMPANY
DOES AND WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
WITH THE COMPANY.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE FOR TESLA
SHAREHOLDERS.
HE IS THE CEO OF TESLA AND TESLA
IS A PUBLIC COMPANY THAT HAS THE
REAL INVESTORS, MOM AND POP
INVESTORS ARE INVESTED IN TESLA,
THAT STOCK IS DOWN ALMOST 30,
40% SINCE HE TOOK OVER TWITTER.
AND IT'S DOWN MORE THAN 66% THIS
YEAR.
ONE ANALYST, DAN IVES, CALLS
THIS A PAINFUL SITUATION FOR
TESLA SHAREHOLDERS.
HE SAYS THAT MUSK IS USING TESLA
AS HIS PERSONAL ATM, TO RAISE
MONEY TO FUND WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT TWITPERPER SO YOU HAVE
TWITTER WHICH IS A SMALL
PLATFORM, PRIVATE COMPANY
GETTING ALL OF THIS ATTENTION
FROM ELON MUSK WHEN YOU HAVE A
BIG PUBLIC COMPANY MAKING
ELECTRIC CARS THAT INVESTORS
HAVE EXPOSURE TO THAT HE'S THE
CEO OF.
THERE ARE BIG SHAREHOLDERS IN
TESLA WHO WANT ELON MUSK TO STAY
FOCUSED ON TESLA, LET GO OF
TWITTER HIRE.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE CRAZY.
TESLA STOCK LOST $565 BILLION IN
MARKET VALUE SINCE PEAKING IN
2021, A YEAR AGO.
>> THERE'S BEEN A RUN ON THESE
TECH STOCKS.
TECH STOCKS ARE DOWN WORSE THAN
THE OVERALL MARKET.
SO THERE'S ALSO THIS HIGH
INTEREST RATE ENVIRONMENT.
AND TECH STOCKS HAVE BEEN OVER
VALUED.
SO A COUPLE THINGS ARE GOING ON
THERE.
BUT TESLA IS DOING WORSE THAN
THE OTHER TECH COMPANIES AND IT
IS A TIME WHEN TESLA
SHAREHOLDERS, MANY THINK THAT
ELON MUSK HAS GOT TO STOP THE
DISTRACTION WITH TWITTER AND GET
FOCUSED BACK AGAIN ON WHAT HIS
CORE -- HIS CORE COMPANIES ARE.
>> I JUST, LIKE I SAID, YOU
COULDN'T -- I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE STRATEGY YOU'RE CONSIDERING
THE MONEY DOES COME FROM TESLA,
RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU HAVE TWITTER AS YOU SAID
SUCKING ALL THE OXYGEN OUT OF
THE ROOM.
>> YOU HAVE 180,000 PEOPLE
JOINED SOMETHING CALLED
MASTEDON.
20,000 PEOPLE HAD BEEN INVITED
TO JOIN POST.
16,000 PEOPLE ACTIVATED.
SO YOU HAVE SMART PEOPLE ON
TWITTER TALKING ABOUT WHERE ARE
WE GOING TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION?
BECAUSE THIS NOISE HERE ON
TWITTER IS NOT GOOD ANYMORE.
>> THAT'S THE POINT.
PEOPLE SAYING TWITTER CAN'T GO
AWAY, IT'S TOO BIG TO FILL.
>> THIS MASTEDON AND POST.
>> IS TWITTER TOO BIG?
PEOPLE ARE LIKE WHY ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT ELON MUSK AND
TWITTER?
WHY ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THIS?
>> I'M SAYING THE SAME THING.
>> HE DOES ELECTRIC CARS.
>> I'M THE TWITTER USER HERE AT
THE TABLE, I LOVE TWITTER AND
THINK IT'S FUNCTIONAL.
>> WOULD YOU GO SOMEPLACE ELSE?
>> DONIE IS TRYING TO GET ME TO
SIGN UP FOR MASTEDON.
SO WE'LL SEE.
>> IT'S AN IMPORTANT NEWS
AGGREGATE BUT ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN PLACES WHERE
THERE'S NOT A FREE MEDIA.
>> AGREE.
>> IRAN AND SUCH.
>> IT'S A GAME CHANGER IN SOME
OF THESE PLACES, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> SOMEONE WILL PICK UP THE
SLACK.
THERE ARE PLATFORMS PEOPLE CAN
GO TO, MASTEDON.
BUT KAITLAN IT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH FOR HER TO GET OFF
TWITTER.
>> I'M NOT PAYING 8 BUCKS A
MONTH FOR A BLUE CHECK.
>> WOULD YOU BE MY FILTER?
>> YES, I'LL GIVE YOU A HEADS